nous avons pour 2021 2022 nous n'avons
pas les chiffres 2022 2023 nous avons
trois signalements pour 1000 élèves dans
le premier degré
13,5 signalement pour 1000 élèves dans
les collèges
5,1 signalement pour 1000 élèves dans
les lycées d'enseignement général et
technologiques et 20,1 signalement pour
1000 élèves dans les lycées
professionnels
dans le premier degré la moitié des
faits de violence déclarées sont commis
à l'encontre d'un enseignant 54% pour
être précis et 5% envers un personnel
autre qu'enseignant les autres faits
déclarés concernent les violences entre
élèves dans le second degré 25% des
faits de violence déclarées sont commis
à l'encontre d'un enseignant 14% à
l'encontre d'un autre personnel
dans le premier degré les principaux
auteurs sont les familles
et dans le second degré ce sont les
élèves
les violences signalées sont
majoritairement des violences verbales
61% dans le premier degré 78% dans le
second degré les violences physiques
représentant 32% des signalements dans
le premier degré 12% dans le second
degré
en complément de ces données civices
nous avons des enquêtes de victimes qui
sont menées directement auprès des
personnels elles permettent d'évaluer le
climat scolaire de mesurer les atteintes
subies par les personnels quels étaient
ou non signalées aux autorités
académiques ou et policières ces
enquêtes de victimes permettent de
compléter l'enquête CIVIS qui ne se
fonde que des faits déclarées au chef
d'établissement et aux inspecteurs de
l'éducation nationale
il faut toutefois préciser que le non
signalement par le chef d'établissement
n'est pas toujours le signe
d'une crainte que la situation empire
dans 65% des cas non signalés le non
signalement provient de ce que la
situation a été traitée par l'agent de
l'éducation nationale lui-même la DEPP a
constitué un échantillon de 45000
personnels du second degré soit à peu
près 10% de la population concernée il y
a un échantillon de 21 000 personnes
dans le premier degré
et ces enquêtes qui existent depuis 2011
ont été étendues en 2019 à titre
d'enseignement principal elle montre que
les violences les plus graves agressions
sexuelles et armes représente 0,5% de
l'ensemble des déclarations soit environ
500 fait par an